today we are answering an age-old very
scientific and important question
what if the moon crashes into earth
it's more interesting and weird than you
probably think
let's start with the basics
why isn't the moon on its way to crash
into us already
[Music]
we know that earth's gravity pulls
everything towards it including the moon
but somehow it stays up as if suspended
by some opposite force
but there is no other force countering
gravity instead the trick to staying up
is a sideways motion that we call an
orbit
you see orbits every day when you throw
a ball it makes a tiny little orbit
the only difference between the balls
orbit and the moons is that the ball
eventually hits the ground
basically the reason is speed
if you could throw your ball fast enough
it would bend around the world and come
back to you
if there were no air slowing it down it
could orbit forever and this is what the
moon does
falling sideways around earth very fast
with no air slowing it down orbiting
earth every 27 days at 3 600 kilometers
an hour
so for the moon to just stop in its
orbit and plummet to the earth would
break more laws of physics than we have
time to explain
so how do we crash it into earth
in a nutshell to change an object's
orbit you need to change its speed which
changes where gravity takes it
but even small changes require enormous
forces which is why all the large
objects in the solar system are so
stable nowadays
according to science the moon is big and
very massive
even igniting billions of rocket engines
all over its surface would barely move
the moon
it looks like nothing short of magic
will make the moon fall so we'll use a
magic spell that slows down the moon so
much that it changes its orbit and
spirals towards earth
to get the most from the experience the
moon will take exactly one year before
it hits earth
ready
three
two
one
magic
month one
[Music]
for the first few days nothing really
changes the moon gets a tiny bit
brighter and scientists get confused but
the rest of us don't notice anything
different
the only noticeable real effect of the
moon on the earth are the tides
tides exist because while earth pulls on
the moon the moon's gravity pulls back
on the earth
since the strength of gravity gets
weaker with distance different parts of
the earth feel a slightly different pull
which causes the earth especially the
oceans to bulge when the moon is above
them and contract a little on the sides
when it's not as earth rotates every day
underneath the moon the moon's influence
fluctuates causing the water level of
the oceans to rise and fall by about
half a meter twice a day
but with the moon drawing ever closer
high tide gets higher every day
at first barely noticeable within a
month the moon has covered half the
distance to the earth and ocean tides
have grown to four meters
every day high tide comes and waves
flood coastal cities and there's no end
in sight
with the moon drawing ever closer tides
rise ever higher inundating another city
and more inhabited land with salty water
every day
month two
by the end of month two the moon has
covered two-thirds of the distance to
earth and global infrastructure is
crumbling as tides rise above 10 meters
displacing up to a billion people who
happen to live near the coastlines
as ports become inoperable shipping
grinds to a halt
not only will it slow down the delivery
of quartzquez products but also less
exciting things like food
global communications fall into disarray
95 of the internet is carried by ocean
crossing cables and while these largely
don't mind the water their terminals on
land do
living inland doesn't guarantee safety
either tidal balls cause rivers to flow
backwards carrying salt water to
contaminate surface and ground water
supplies
gas shortages follow as all refineries
near the coast are abandoned
countries are left with the supplies
they had on their shelves and strict
rationing will begin
in the cities chaos rains during the
scavenging hours of low tide while
survivors take refuge in high rises when
the water returns
month three
three months in and the moon is close
enough to disrupt communication and
navigation satellites
while it's normally far too distant for
its gravity to cause any major problems
for our satellites the closer it gets
the more warped their orbits become
as their fuel for orbital corrections
runs out satellites careen out of
control
months four and five
on earth the tides are rapidly growing
to about 30 meters and will be reaching
100 meters in height in a few short
weeks
at low tide the ocean recedes hundreds
of kilometers exposing the continental
shelf like vast deserts while at high
tide walls of water drown agriculture
houses and skyscrapers
and now almost five months in the
apocalypse has finished its warm-up act
since the oceans are on average only
three kilometers deep the tides have
reached their maximum
up until now the water in the oceans
could flow absorbing most of the moon's
gravitational squeezing but now the
earth itself is really feeling the
squeeze of the ever-approaching moon
these aren't so much tides of water but
tides of rock
the squeezing of the planet combined
with the weight of quintillions of tons
of water sloshing on and off the
tectonic plates creates enormous
stresses below and begins to cause
earthquakes of increasing magnitude and
intensity it's impossible to say how
serious these earthquakes might be or
where they occur but like a child
jumping on their bed until it breaks no
good can come of it
strong tidal forces lead to volcanism on
other planets and moons on earth
squeezing the planet disrupts the magma
reservoirs inside the crust triggering
sizeable climate altering eruptions in
chile new zealand yellowstone and
elsewhere
meanwhile watching patiently above is
the moon
still no bigger in the sky than a small
cloud
within 75 000 kilometers of earth it is
bright enough to illuminate the night
sky like twilight
months six and seven
after half a year the moon is entering
the space once occupied by
geosynchronous satellites where it
orbits earth every 24 hours it appears
to float at one spot in the sky unmoving
cycling through a full set of phases
every day but only visible to half the
planet
with the moon stationary above the earth
the tides seem to freeze in place
half the world flooded half with its
water seemingly returned to the sea as
if earth is holding its breath to
prepare for the worst
as the moon sinks further you might
wonder if its gravity would overpower
earth's pulling you up and ending your
misery
fortunately not
the earth's surface gravity is about six
times stronger than the moons so even if
the moon were hovering right on top of
you you would still stay on the ground
on the moon things are different though
the near side of the moon is more
strongly affected by earth's gravity so
during the next few months it starts to
stretch forward towards the earth into
something of an egg triggering deep
moonquakes as the lunar rock flexes and
changes shape
though barely noticeable now this squish
will grow to hundreds of kilometers in a
matter of months
months eight to eleven
at this point the apocalypse has arrived
and we can summarize the months before
the crash as everybody left has a really
bad time
the tides sweeping over the earth slow
down and then reverse their direction
because the moon now orbits earth faster
than it rotates
the planet will experience an abundance
of earthquakes and volcanism
massive amounts of volcanic aerosols
rise high into the stratosphere shiny
enough to reflect sunlight back into
space
what little light gets through is rust
red and is periodically diminished by
daily eclipses
the result is a rapid global cooling
with acid rains and summer snows killing
even the hardiest plants
the clock runs out on civilization
billions have perished while an x-shaped
moon is still drawing closer
let's get ready for the grand finale
month 12
finally at the end of the year the moon
has reached the rash limit
that's the point where earth's
gravitational pull on the moon is
stronger than the moon's own gravity
things on the lunar surface start
falling towards earth and by the time it
crosses ten thousand kilometers the
entire moon disintegrates into rubble
smearing itself into a massive ring
system around the earth
fortunately the moon's disintegration
means the misery on earth has ended
no moon means the general apocalyptic
nature of things comes to a halt
the oceans recede flowing off the land
one last time
any survivors are treated to a view of
tremendous arches spanning the sky
glimmering in the sunlight illuminating
the night sky more brilliantly than any
full moon ever could while meteor
showers of moon dust fill the sky
it's hard to say what happens next but
the tranquility may be short-lived
if too much moon dust rains down
friction heats the atmosphere possibly
boiling the oceans
if not the enormous shadows cast by the
rings combined with all the volcanic and
meteoric aerosols block even more
sunlight and a period of runaway cooling
could begin that freezes much of earth's
surface solid
in any case at some point people will
emerge again from submarines or bunkers
or mountaintops
they will not have a great time before
rebuilding civilization and their
success is not guaranteed
but at least they'll be trying to do so
with beautiful rings in the sky
[Music]
so how do you calculate that sort of
thing well you just need a bit of
insanity and some maths if you need to
brush up on the latter our friends from
brilliant are the perfect coaches to
turn your curiosity into practical
skills
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that makes science accessible
with a hands-on approach
more than 60 interactive courses like
the joy of problem solving or scientific
thinking give you the tools to crack
problems in maths science and computer
science in a way that feels more like
playing a game than doing homework
lessons will surprise you with
storytelling code writing tasks and
interactive challenges basically using
whatever keeps you interested and
entertained all the content is
interactive instead of just reading and
listening to explanations you drag and
drop manipulate shapes and diagrams make
selections and answer questions
this way you learn something almost
without you noticing it
and tiny step by step you'll build up
your long-term understanding of science
and get closer to your stem goals
to start looking at the world of science
from a different perspective go to
brilliant.org slash nutshell and sign up
for free
and there's an extra perk for kutzkazak
viewers the first 200 people to use the
link get 20 percent off their annual
membership which unlocks all of
brilliant courses in maths science and
computer science
at kurzgesagt we love to create things
that seem impossible at first brilliant
can help you acquire the skills to do
that
this year we'll release three very
special limited edition pins the first
one is this very shiny moon crash pin
set pre-order is available for only 72
hours so you can order it now and then
never again be sure to watch out for pin
number two and three to complete your
12022 collection
[Music]
you